En términos de desarrollo económico, fue una gran inversión.
Pero en la última década, se ven los efectos combinados del cambio climático,
el crecimiento demográfico y la competencia por los recursos hídricos
poner en peligro estas arterias vitales y los recursos hídricos.
Esta gráfica muestra el cambio en el nivel del lago Mead
ocurrido en los últimos 15 años.
Se puede ver a partir del año 2000 más o menos,
que el nivel del lago comenzó a descender.
Y disminuyó a un ritmo tal
que podría haber dejado sin agua potable a Las Vegas.
La ciudad llegó a estar tan preocupada por esto
que recientemente construyeron una nueva estructura de toma de agua potable
que se conoce como la "Tercer paja"
para extraer agua de las profundidades del lago.
Los retos asociados con el suministro de agua a una ciudad moderna
no se restringen a suroeste de EE.UU.
En el año 2007, la tercera ciudad más grande de Australia, Brisbane,
llegó en 6 meses a quedarse sin agua.
Un drama similar sucede hoy en São Paulo, Brasil,
donde el depósito principal de la ciudad
ha pasado de estar completamente lleno en 2010,
a estar casi vacío hoy
mientras la ciudad se acerca a los Juegos Olímpicos de 2016.
Para quienes tenemos la suerte
de vivir en una de las grandes ciudades del mundo,
en realidad, nunca hemos experimentado los efectos de una sequía catastrófica.
Nos gusta quejarnos de las duchas marinas que tenemos que tomar.
Nos gusta que nuestros vecinos vean nuestros autos sucios y el césped marrón.
Pero nunca nos confrontamos con la perspectiva de abrir el grifo
y ver que no sale nada.
Y eso es porque cuando las cosas fueron mal en el pasado,
siempre fue posible ampliar un depósito
o cavar más profundos en pozos de agua subterránea.
Cuando se reserven todos los recursos hídricos,
no será viable confiar en esta probada y verdadera
manera de autoabastecernos con agua.
Algunos piensan que resolveremos el problema del agua urbana
tomando el agua de nuestros vecinos rurales.
Pero eso es un enfoque plagado de peligros políticos, legales y sociales.
E incluso si tenemos éxito tomando el agua de nuestros vecinos rurales,
solo transferimos el problema a otra persona
y hay una gran probabilidad de que vuelva e impacte en nosotros
en los precios de los alimentos
y en el daño a los ecosistemas acuáticos dependientes del agua.
Creo que hay una mejor manera de resolver la crisis del agua urbana
y creo que es abriendo cuatro nuevas fuentes de agua locales
que yo comparo con los grifos.
Si podemos hacer inversiones inteligentes en estas nuevas fuentes de agua
en los próximos años,
podemos resolver nuestro problema del agua urbana
y disminuir la probabilidad de atravesar
los efectos de una sequía catastrófica.
Si Uds. me hubieran dicho hace 20 años
que una ciudad moderna puede existir sin un suministro de agua importada,
probablemente lo habría catalogado como soñador realista y desinformado.
Pero mis propias experiencias, al trabajar
en algunas de las ciudades más sedientas del mundo en las últimas décadas
me han demostrado que tenemos la tecnología y la capacidad de gestión
para abandonar la dependencia de agua importada,
y de eso quiero hablar esta noche.
La primera fuente de suministro de agua local que necesitamos desarrollar
para resolver el problema del agua urbana
fluirá con el agua de lluvia que cae en nuestras ciudades.
Una de las grandes tragedias de desarrollo urbano
es que conforme las ciudades crecieron,
empezamos a cubrir todas las superficies con hormigón y asfalto.
Y al hacerlo, tuvimos que construir las alcantarillas
para recoger el agua caída sobre las ciudades
antes de que pudiera causar inundaciones,
y eso es un desperdicio de un recurso vital del agua.
Déjenme poner un ejemplo.
Esta gráfica muestra que el volumen de agua
que podrían ser recogidos en la ciudad de San José
si hubieran recogido el agua de lluvia caída en los límites de la ciudad.
En la intersección de la línea azul y la negra se puede ver
que si San José pudiera capturar la mitad del agua caída en la ciudad,
tendrían suficiente agua para abastecerse todo un año.
Sé lo que algunos de Uds. piensan.
"La respuesta a nuestro problema es comenzar a construir grandes tanques
y adherirlos a los bajantes de nuestros canales del tejado,
para la recogida de agua de lluvia".
Es una idea que podría funcionar en algunos lugares.
Pero si uno vive en un lugar donde llueve principalmente en invierno
y la mayor parte de la demanda de agua es en el verano,
no es una forma muy rentable para resolver un problema de agua.
Y si se experimentan los efectos de una sequía de varios años,
como lo hace California en la actualidad, no se puede construir un tanque
de agua de lluvia suficientemente grande para resolver el problema.
Creo que hay muchas maneras más prácticas
para recoger el agua de lluvia que cae sobre nuestras ciudades,
y es recogiéndola y dejando que se infiltre en el suelo.
Después de todo, muchas ciudades se asientan
en la parte superior de un sistema de almacenamiento de agua natural
que puede acomodar grandes volúmenes de agua.
Por ejemplo, históricamente, Los Ángeles obtenía
cerca de un tercio de su suministro de agua de un acuífero
que subyace en el Valle de San Fernando.
Al fijarnos en el agua del canalón de lluvia
que se esparce por su césped y fluye por el sumidero,
uno podría decir: "¿Realmente quiero beber eso?"
La respuesta es que no la querrán beber
hasta que se haya tratado un poco.
Y el reto al que nos enfrentamos con el agua de lluvia urbana
es recoger el agua, limpiar el agua
y almacenarla en el subsuelo.
Y eso es exactamente lo que la ciudad de Los Ángeles hace
con un nuevo proyecto en Burbank, California.
Esta gráfica muestra el parque de aguas pluviales que están construyendo
enganchando una serie de sistemas de recogida de aguas pluviales
o alcantarillas, y encaminando el agua hacia una cantera de gravilla abandonada.
El agua que se almacena en la cantera
se hace pasar lentamente por un humedal artificial,
y después pasa a un campo de bolas
y se filtra en el suelo,
reponiendo el acuífero de agua potable de la ciudad.
Y en el proceso de pasar a través del humedal
y de infiltración e el suelo,
el agua encuentra microbios que viven en la superficie de las plantas
y la superficie del suelo,
y que purifica el agua.
Y si el agua todavía no está lo suficientemente limpia para beber
tras haber pasado por este proceso de tratamiento natural,
la ciudad puede tratarla de nuevo
cuando la devuelven a los acuíferos subterráneos
antes de suministrarla a la gente para beber.
El segundo grifo que se debe abrir para resolver el problema del agua urbana
fluirá con las aguas residuales
que sale de las plantas de tratamiento de aguas residuales.
Muchos probablemente están familiarizados con el concepto de agua reciclada.
Probablemente han visto signos como este
que informa de que los arbustos, la mediana de la carretera
y el campo de golf local
se riegan con agua
que solía estar en una planta de tratamiento de aguas residuales.
Hemos estado haciendo esto un par de décadas.
Pero lo que estamos aprendiendo de nuestra experiencia
es que este enfoque es mucho más caro de lo que imaginábamos,
Porque una vez que construimos los primeros sistemas de reciclaje de agua
cerca de la planta de tratamiento de aguas residuales,
debemos construir redes de tuberías más largas y más largas
para llevar el agua a donde tiene que ir.
Y eso se convierte en prohibitivo en cuanto a costos.
Lo que vemos es que
una solución mucho más rentable y práctica de reciclaje de aguas residuales
es convertir las aguas residuales tratadas en agua potable
mediante un proceso de dos pasos.
En el primer paso se presuriza el agua
y se pasa a través de una membrana de ósmosis inversa:
una membrana de plástico delgada, permeable
que permite que las moléculas de agua pasen
pero atrapa y retiene sales, virus y productos químicos orgánicos
que pueden estar presentes en las aguas residuales.
En el segundo paso,
añadimos una pequeña cantidad de peróxido de hidrógeno
e irradiamos luz ultravioleta en el agua.
La luz ultravioleta desintegra el peróxido de hidrógeno
en dos partes denominadas radicales hidroxilos,
y estos radicales hidroxilos son formas de oxígeno muy potentes
que descomponen la mayoría de los productos químicos orgánicos.
Tras haber pasado el agua por este proceso de dos etapas,
ya se puede beber.
Lo sé,
he estudiado el agua reciclada
utilizando todas las técnicas de medición conocida por la ciencia moderna
durante los últimos 15 años.
Hemos detectado algunos productos químicos
que pueden aparecer en la primera etapa en el proceso,
pero en el momento en que llegamos a la segunda etapa,
en el proceso de oxidación avanzada,
rara vez vemos algún producto químico presente.
Y eso contrasta con lo que se da por sentado sobre el suministro de agua
que bebemos todo el tiempo.
Hay otra manera de reciclar el agua.
Es un humedal de tratamiento de ingeniería que construimos hace poco
en el río Santa Ana, en el sur de California.
El humedal de tratamiento recibe el agua de una parte del río Santa Ana
que en verano se compone casi en total de efluentes de aguas residuales
de ciudades como Riverside y San Bernardino.
El agua entra en nuestro humedal de tratamiento,
es expuesto a la luz solar y a las algas
que descomponen los productos químicos orgánicos,
eliminando los nutrientes e inactivando los patógenos en el agua.
El agua se devuelve al río Santa Ana,
que fluye hacia abajo a Anaheim,
se almacena en Anaheim y se infiltra en el suelo,
y se convierte en el agua potable de la ciudad de Anaheim,
completando el viaje desde las alcantarillas de Condado de Riverside
al suministro de agua potable del Condado de Orange.
Se podría pensar que esta idea de aguas residuales potables
es una fantasía futurista o que no se hace comúnmente.
Pues bien, en California, ya reciclamos unos 151 500 millones de litros al año
de aguas residuales mediante el proceso de tratamiento avanzado de dos etapas
Del que estaba hablando.
Eso es suficiente agua para el suministro de cerca de un millón de personas
si fuera su suministro de agua del suelo.
El tercer grifo que debemos abrir no será un grifo en absoluto,
será una especie de grifo virtual,
será la conservación del agua que logremos hacer.
Y el lugar que debemos pensar para la conservación del agua al aire libre
porque en California y otras ciudades estadounidenses modernas,
cerca de la mitad de nuestro uso del agua sucede al aire libre.
En la actual sequía,
hemos visto que es posible
que el césped y las plantas sobrevivan
con la mitad de agua.
Así que no hay necesidad de pintar de verde el cemento,
poner césped artificial y comprar cactus.
Podemos tener un paisaje californiano con detectores de humedad del suelo
y controladores de riego inteligentes
y además tener paisajes verdes en nuestras ciudades.
El cuarto y último grifo de agua que hay que abrir
para resolver nuestro problema del agua urbana
fluirá con agua de mar desalinizada.
Sé lo que muchos probablemente oyeron sobre la desalinización del agua de mar.
"Es algo bueno, si se tiene mucho aceite, no un montón de agua
y si uno no se preocupa por el cambio climático".
La desalinización de agua marina supone siempre un alto consumo energético.
Pero esa caracterización de desalinizar agua marina
como un imposible está irremediablemente fuera de fecha.
Se han hecho enormes progresos en la desalinización de agua marina
en las últimas dos décadas.
Esta foto muestra
la mayor planta de desalinización de agua de mar en el hemisferio occidental
que se está construyendo al norte de San Diego.
En comparación con la planta de desalinización de agua marina
construida en Santa Bárbara hace 25 años,
esta planta de tratamiento utilizará la mitad de la energía
para producir un litro de agua.
Y aunque la desalinización de agua marina ya no consume tanta energía,
no significa que deberíamos construir plantas de desalinización en todas partes.
Entre las diferentes opciones que tenemos,
es la que probablemente consume más energía
y potencialmente la más dañina para el medio ambiente
entre las opciones de crear un suministro de agua local.
Así que ahí está.
Con estas cuatro fuentes de agua,
podemos alejarnos de nuestra dependencia en agua importada.
Mediante la reforma de nuestra paisaje y nuestras propiedades,
podemos reducir el consumo de agua al aire libre en un 50 %,
aumentando así. el suministro de agua en un 25 %.
Podemos reciclar el agua de la alcantarilla,
lo que aumenta el suministro de agua en un 40 %.
Y podemos marcar la diferencia combinando
recolección de aguas pluviales y desalinización de agua marina.
Por lo tanto, creemos un sistema de suministro de agua
capaz de soportar cualquiera desafío al que
el cambio climático nos someterá en los próximos años.
Creemos un suministro de agua que utiliza fuentes locales
dejando más agua en el ambiente para los peces y los alimentos.
Creemos un sistema de agua en consonancia con valores ambientales externos.
Y hagámoslo para nuestros hijos y nietos
y digámosles que este es el sistema
del que deben cuidar en el futuro
porque es nuestra última oportunidad para crear un nuevo sistema de agua.
Muchas gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)